[Music]  listen carefully  watch learn mortal kombat has begun  there's a war coming need to fight  before it's too late  [Music]  get over here  mortal kombat in theaters and on hbo max  the exact same day rated r  [Music]  it's all real that dragon marking  it's an invitation means you've been  chosen  for what mortal kombat  [Music]  we don't have much time  well if they want to fight let's give  them one  mortal combat who's first  throughout history different cultures  reference a great tournament  mortal kombat  name's jax sonia luke kung laos  cool i am  a dragon marking it's an invitation  means you've been chosen for what mortal  kombat  [Music]  we don't have much time  well if they want to fight let's give  them money  [Music]  mortal kombat who's first  in theaters and on hbo max april 16  rated r  you